GUILHERME PAULOVIC:
My name is Paulovic.
I'm a Product
Manager of PlayKids.
It means that, in
my day-to-day job,
I talk with parents and kids and
families and businesspeople--
like the CEO of PlayKids is
over here-- and designers
in order to get information
to build apps for kids.
And I'd like to talk today is
about-- imagine the app store.
There's over 100,000
apps in the app stores.
So a parent decides
to download an app.
And then he presents the app
to his little one-- to the kid.
And the kid enjoys
it and loves it.
And you start trying to sell
your product to the parent.
And you get it.
And there's this whole
cycle that is happening.
And after that-- after he
downloads or she downloads--
and the kid enjoys with
the app, and he subscribes
or she subscribes
to the app, how
do you keep these subscribers
engaged to these experiences.
So this is what I'd
like to talk today--
what we learned so far
in PlayKids in creating
subscribers in a different
way than our users.
But first, I'd like to give
you some background on what
is PlayKids, and to get a sense
of the size of the problem
and the scale of the problem
that we're talking about.
PlayKids is the most curated
educational and entertainment
platform for kids in the world.
We have books and games and
videos through various apps.
And we deliver entertainment
and education for kids.
To give you more sense
on how big is it,
PlayKids is watched over
150 million videos a month,
and kids play over 100
million games a month.
And as you can see in
our engagement numbers,
we have over 100 countries
that have already
downloaded PlayKids.
And kids are really
enjoying this-- PlayKids.
And this has to do pretty
much with the industry
and what's happening right now.
Last year, people
started getting more time
seeing and watching videos and
entertainment on their mobile
rather than TV.
And the same thing is happening
to the kids industry as well.
So although the industry's
shifting from TV and to mobile,
it's expected of you to
deliver a great experience
on mobile for those cases.
But there is a thing
that is not changing.
That is the needs of the parents
and the needs of the kids--
the motivations for
them to get together,
the motivation for them
to download an app,
or even to watch a video,
or to get entertainment,
or to look for education.
SPEAKER 1: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SPEAKER 2: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
GUILHERME PAULOVIC: I don't
know if you got this--
if you got this translation.
OK.
And the thing is she and parents
are looking for ways for kids
to play and interact
with a safer place,
where the kids are safe, and
they can learn from playing.
And kids, otherwise,
they want a cool place
where they get superpowers,
and they can learn,
and they can paint
and create things.
And the mix of the things
is the base of PlayKids.
Why do we learn is upon that.
Our product is created
and based on this.
So PlayKids is based on
a subscription model.
And at first, as we
launched PlayKids,
we thought that our
life would be like this.
So we just decided a
subscription model,
and money would come
month after month.
And so we discovered
that is not as easy
as it seems because people
canceled their subscription,
or there's something
that's happened
to their subscription
that is canceled,
or they uninstalled the app.
And they don't feel
like the app is OK.
You have to update the app.
So we started thinking
that, well, it's
not only a thing that you
just apply a business model.
You have to act like
a subscription model.
And to do this, you have
to think that you are not
creating an app.
You have to start thinking about
you are creating a service.
And people are paying for this
service month after month.
So you have to continuously
be adding value
to the subscribers.
So along all of this journey, I
created a top list of nine ways
that PlayKids has
evolved with parents
with this kind of
subscription base,
and what we learned so far,
and how we are adding value
to our subscriber base.
The first thing is that
PlayKids is moving from an app
to a service.
It means that we had
only one app in 2013,
and we moved it to over
four apps this year.
We moved from only an
app that was giving
videos and games for parents.
For today, a bundle of apps
that we can provide casual games
for kids, for older kids,
and over 1,000 books for kids
as well, and a communication
tool for families,
and more and more
videos on PlayKids.
And the very innovative
thing is that with just one
subscription, we can
unlock all the content
across all our apps.
And this increased a
lot the willingness
to pay of the parents in this.
It's as much as this.
This is a subscription
banner that we
were selling all
the apps of PlayKids
within the same subscription.
And these are the results
just after the launch.
We increased 81% in
sales, and bringing people
to subscribe to our service by
providing a variety of apps--
a bundle of apps with
the same subscription.
And also, by creating
this platform,
we could announce
ourselves as a service.
So we created a feature
across all our apps
that would
cross-promote our apps.
And then we could make a
more better understanding
for parents that we
were not just an app,
but a bundle of apps.
And by then downloading
one app, they
could use all the content
of the other apps as well.
And one app
complements each other.
It increases more and more the
willingness to pay for parents.
And we also have
PlayKids catalog
that we have a lot of videos.
In over 28 countries,
every country
has a different catalog that
we will license content.
And every week, every Friday,
we launch our new episodes
or new videos or new characters.
And maintaining these
launches every week,
there's a lot of work
to get done to get this.
And this constant
update-- the constant look
for prospection for new
characters, characters
that kids love, characters
that parents care about.
And this updating our
services and updating our apps
frequently with this creates
a sense to the parents
that it is a service.
It's not an app.
It's not finished.
It's constantly evolved.
And for us, it's very important
to have a mix of local content
like [INAUDIBLE] in Brazil,
or Daniel Tiger in the US,
with famous and well-known
characters such as Pocoyo
or Backyardigans and so on.
Everything that we
design on PlayKids
is for the amusement
of the little ones.
If you don't design
for the little ones,
we are doing our job wrong.
Because they are
going to use it.
They're going to enjoy it.
They're going to learn
things by using PlayKids.
So they are our user.
Our customer is the parent.
You have to convince
the parents to keep
subscribing to our service.
But they have to
trust us that we
created a real good experience
to their little ones.
Just an example on PlayKids.
Just one week before we launched
the version 1 [INAUDIBLE]
PlayKids, we designed
the app to stream video.
We with the streamed
video instead of download.
And we brought some
kids to the office.
And we gave them the app
for them to interact with.
And we did all the setup.
I don't know if you already
have [INAUDIBLE] with kids.
But nothing happens as
the way you expected.
Because you have all this setup.
And we brought the kids.
And they tapped to watch
a video, and the spinner,
loading.
The kids just put the
tablet away and just started
playing with another toy.
So by that moment,
we knew we have
to design with the kid in mind.
So just one week
before launching,
we said we are not going to have
a stream as the full version.
As a standard of PlayKids, we
are going to have the download.
And while we are
downloading, we created games
so kids could watch videos.
While they download a video,
they can play some games.
And they come back
and watch the videos
when it is finished, and so on.
So we design for kids.
And every little detail is
very important for them.
They expect everything
to be interactive.
And everything-- every detail
detail of PlayKids is you
can tap, and you
expect an animation.
And in the end of the
day, if you are not
creating a good product--
a good toy for the kids--
why would the parent
care about it?
If the kids don't like it,
why would someone buy it?
We also have learned
during all the way
some themes that kids
like, such as music
telling about ABC songs.
They're telling
about basic stuff
and learning basic things.
And some craft
classes-- learning
how to fold origami or
something like that.
And some animal songs that
would place some animals
in some [? topics ?]
like bullying or lying
and something like that.
So we learned with our data,
and then with some tests, what
kids would love to
see, and then started
creating our own content.
And we brought this
to the platform.
So we brought it to
the PlayKids so parents
could see that there's someone
behind this thinking about how
to well treat their kids.
And this is adding value
to the platform as well.
And we have over 50 episodes
of our original content,
with over 100 million
views already.
And just for comparison,
what we understood
is that, by understanding the
kids and using some metrics,
we could create some episodes
that were engaging more-- kids
were watching more and more
and more than some other ones
like this place.
You can compare ABC episode
with the Backyardigan ones.
Kids were watching more and
replaying it more and more.
Another thing that
we have talked here
already is we created
special collections.
And this is very important
across all our apps.
Our books app has
special collections
for special dates
such as the Halloween,
or the Easter, back
to school, or summer.
And our PlayKids TV app
has some special train cars
that have some videos
for those dates.
And this is really
important because kids,
they are in the school,
or they have some friends,
and they're talking
about the things.
Oh, oh, what is your
costume for Halloween?
Oh, we're going back to school.
And this is a real link
from the offline world
to the online world.
So when a kid sees this,
he likes it, she likes it.
And the parent
expects this as well.
We also adapt our icon
to those special dates,
as we talked before.
Actually, we talked a
lot about icons today.
It was a great lesson.
This other thing that we
do is social media buzz.
Every new launch that we
have, every new episode,
or every new feature, we try
to push on the channels that
reach the parents
for the parents
to know that we are caring about
it, updating, bringing content,
and making their service alive.
So they're investing
money every month in it.
And we're telling them that
you're in a safe place,
we're creating a
great app for kids,
and the service is evolving.
We treat our subscribers,
as well, in a different way.
We have a really detailed
customer journey.
And to sum up, we
have four states here.
When someone enters on
PlayKids as a new user,
and then we give a seven-day
free trial so the user
can try PlayKids for free.
And then she becomes
an active subscriber.
And then if she cancels
or has some error,
and if she churns-- we
call this user churn.
And each of these phases,
we have a different message
through a different channel.
Or we send emails telling
about the subscription's over.
Or during the period, we
send emails telling you
what is going on and
what's new on PlayKids.
Or we send a push
notification telling
them there's some billing
problem, and so on.
So this is very
important because this
is a way to recover
people that have churned.
And you have to reconvince
parents for them
to go back to the service.
And it's a good way also to
make parents know that you
are evolving the product.
So the app is a
channel for a kid.
And you have to think
and figure out ways
to reach the parents outside.
We also run a lot of icon tests.
And as we talked today, we
have to do some experiments,
because it drives
a lot of results.
The last one is the
most successful icon
ever on PlayKids.
It drove a lot of traction,
a lot of user downloads.
And we use the Google
Developer Console experience
to try these new things.
We also try some
screenshots experiments
to see which message
conveys better to the parent
compared to another one.
What should be the two first
screenshots of the store?
What should be the description?
What should be the icons?
So we can test it.
And then, as we learn
it, we can spread this
into all the platforms as well.
And the bottom line on all
of this is parents care a lot
on what their kids are
playing, what their kids are
learning from playing.
And the first thing
that we learned
is that you have
to design for kids.
It's mandatory.
You have to create a great
product with great content that
makes sense for kids.
And then we have to keep
your service always updated.
And there is a difference
from thinking of app
and thinking of service.
You have to think that your
app is a way to communicate
within your service.
As you have this in mind,
you can reach parents
in another way so you can
communicate properly with them
and show all the
value of your product.
And making various constant
updates, as well make
it look local with
local content,
and localization as well,
and all the things that
makes the content feel local.
Like if you use
PlayKids in Brazil,
it looks like there's
a Brazilian app.
But if you use it in the US,
there's a voiceover in English.
There is all the content
that is very now in the US.
If you go to Spain,
it's all in Spanish,
and it has all the
voiceovers, all the characters
are speaking Spanish, and so on.
And you have to properly
communicate with the parents.
You have to send a right message
to the right state of the user
engagement.
It does not make sense
to change a message
to convince a parent to
subscribe to your service
if he is already or she's
already a subscriber.
And you have to put your own
personality in the service.
Or by creating our own
content like we did.
We created our own characters.
We created our own shows.
And we put it on TV.
But parents always
expect their kids
to learn from what
they are doing.
And they are very proud on this.
And so these are
some of the points
that we're working on PlayKids
to make more clear to parents
that we are a service, and
that our service is always
being updated.
So I hope this can
be useful for you.
We learned a lot
in this journey.
And keep creating
great apps for kids.
And keep making them smile.
So thank you.